[Applause]
an expectant crowd outside yangon's
insane prison as a bus emerged the buzz
of excitement shouts and Applause for
those inside
looking happy and a little flustered
meow a one of myanmar's most prominent
pro-democracy activists he was arrested
immediately after the coup in February
2021 and he had a message as he stepped
out as a free man
whatever the situation I will be with
the people of Myanmar I will stand with
them for the sake of the country he told
the waiting crowd nearly two years in
jail appear to have left him unbowed
earlier in the day state TV announced
that
5774 prisoners would be released
including 712 sentence for political
offenses and three foreigners Mr Chandon
Australia
an economist and advisor to Ang sang
tsuchi arrested after the coup serving
three years for treason Vicki Bowman a
former British ambassador to Myanmar
serving a one-year sentence for
immigration offenses and Japanese
filmmaker torukubota sentenced to 10
years for filming an anti-coo protest
prisoner releases are quite common in
Myanmar but this number is relatively
large and this many political prisoners
haven't been released together since the
coup but a much larger number of people
remain in prison 700 plus people is
important but this is still a drop in
the bucket compared to what they have
the number of people that they're
holding you know you've got you know
rests that are well over 12 000 people
that have been held in you know over 2
500 people killed
a blacked out SUV was seen leaving the
prison with a police escort myanmar's
military has said they were deported
upon release
perhaps hoping that might lift some of
the international pressure that's been
building
Gallego Al Jazeera